direction en bois à présent la chapelle
saint-hubert situé au sein du château
royal s'apprêtent à subir d'importants
travaux de rénovation
un chantier qui s'élève à près de 2
millions d'euros mais la fondation
saint-louis va bénéficier d'une aide
exceptionnelle de l'état dans le cadre
du plan de relance pour aider les
monuments historiques
explications aurélie renault et paul
boyer l'iconique chapelle saint-hubert
abrite la tombe du génie léonard de
vinci à l'automne un travail de
restauration sera amorcée sur les
charpentes et les couvertures alors le
coût global c'est à peu près un million
huit uniquement sur cette chapelle
sachant que nous avons deux chantiers le
confortement d'un rempart qui sera à peu
près équivalent sur le plan du budget un
million huit et donc l'état va nous
aider à hauteur de 60% dans cette
entreprise 100 millions d'euros celles
enveloppe du plan de relance au niveau
national dont deux millions sont dédiés
à la culture et au patrimoine
un soutien d'urgence pour un secteur en
souffrance le plan de relance il est là
pour accompagner la gestion de l'urgence
accompagner un certain nombre
d'entreprises d'avenir mais aussi pour
valoriser le patrimoine qui est un
vecteur d'attractivité économique très
important dans ce département
habitué à recevoir près de 350 mille
visiteurs chaque année dans le château
c'est le silence qui résonne 0 euros
côté billetterie pour la fondation
saint-louis propriétaire du château et
ce malgré l'urgence des travaux
c'est effectivement une chance pour la
fondation saint-louis qui aurait dû
réaliser ces travaux de toute façon mais
qui aurait été extrêmement embarrassés
si elle avait dû être seul par ricochet
le plan relancera l'activité des
entreprises spécialisées dans les
monuments historiques
elles sont situées dans un rayon d'une
centaine de kilomètres autour du château